Sounds good Sarah.
So like Sarah said,
the first step will be to get her
changes into my local repository.
Right now if I run git log on the master
branch, I don't see Sarah's commit.
So I'll need to run git pull.
And I'll pull from the origin
remote in the master branch.
Recall that if I wanted to take another
look at Sarah's changes first, I could
run git fetch, examine the changes, and
then run git merge origin/master master.
But since I already know what her
changes are, I ran git pull instead.
Now I want these changes
to be incorporated into
the different-oil branch, so
I'll run git checkout different-oil, and
then git merge master different-oil.
As expected, I get a merge conflict.
I'll resolve the conflict keeping both
of our changes, so now there's three
quarters of the cup of canola oil,
and then I'll commit the merge.
Now I'll run git log, and
I can see that this branch
contains both of our changes.
Here's where the more oil
pull request was merged, and
here's the merge commit
that I just made.
Now go ahead and repeat these
steps in your own repository.
In order to get Sarah's changes to
appear in your fork, you'll need to
download and run the code we've
provided in the downloadables section.
There are instructions on how to
do this in the instructor's notes.
Now this code won't actually
make a pull request, so
you won't see a pull request
appear in your repository.
Instead, if you look at your
commit history on GitHub,
you should see a commit that looks like
this one, saying, merge pull request.
And you should also see Sarah's commit,
adding more oil so the cake is moist.
Once you've run the code to
simulate Sarah's changes,
update your local repository
with Sarah's changes and
merge your master branch into your
different-oil branch, like I did.
Finally, push your different-oil
branch to your fork to
update your pull request,
which I haven't done yet.
Once you're done, here are some
things you can check to verify that
everything has gone correctly.
Your local master branch should
contain Sarah's changes.
Your local different-oil branch
should contain the merge commit,
merging Sarah's changes
into your branch.
The same merge commit should be
visible on your pull request.
And the merge button on your
pull request should be green.
Check these boxes once these
things are true for you.